faltan seis días para las elecciones de
medio término y los demócratas refuerzan
sus puntos más débiles el expresidente
Barack Obama Fue llamado al rescate para
hacer campaña por su partido el martes
por la noche estuvo en Nevada para
impulsar a la senadora demócrata
Katherine cortes más tú considerada como
un eslabón frágil de Cara a los comicios
[Aplausos]
la razón por la que estoy aquí es simple
estoy aquí para pedirles que voten
estoy aquí para pedirles que voten por
los miembros del Congreso y para enviar
a Katherine cortés masto de vuelta al
senado de Estados Unidos
visitó Florida un estado históricamente
péndulo pero que se inclina hacia los
republicanos desde hace varios años el
presidente intentó movilizar a sus
electores alrededor de temas como el
aborto o la seguridad social
vienen por tu seguridad social y
Medicare lo dicen en voz alta significa
que cada cinco años El Congreso votará
para recortar reducir o eliminar
completamente la seguridad social y
Medicare si no hacen nada desaparecerá
no es una broma
en Pensilvania otro estado péndulo el
contrato demócrata al senado perdió la
ventaja que tenía frente al republicano
un famoso médico respaldado por Donald
Trump
quiero ir a Washington y aportar
equilibrio para que las discusiones
partidistas aparezcan y abordemos los
problemas que aquejan a la gente en
Pensilvania y en todo este hermoso país
Aunque la elección sigue siendo muy
impredecible podría perder el control de
la cámara de representantes e incluso el
control del senado el 8 de noviembre
también tendrán lugar elecciones de
gobernadores en varios estados claves